this hard hat went out so they had to
resuscitating twice Demar Hamlin's Uncle
Dorian Glenn is speaking out about his
nephew's condition after suffering a
cardiac arrest during Monday night's
game between the Buffalo Bills and the
Cincinnati Bengals so when someone has a
Sudden Impact or blunt trauma to the
chest if it happens at a specific part
of the cardiac cycle then that can lead
to a ventricular arrhythmia or an
unstable heart arrhythmia which can
ultimately lead to sudden Cardiac Arrest
the incident occurred during the first
quarter of the game after Damar made a
tackle stood up and immediately
collapsed on the field Demar was down
for at least 15 minutes paramedics
administered CPR he was taken off the
field in an ambulance and the game was
postponed I mean it was tough like
you're just seeing everyone's reactions
it was it was a little scary I mean
because you know the hit didn't look bad
but then you saw everyone's reactions
you're like what are we missing like
what's going on the NFL later released a
statement confirming that the 24 year
old athlete suffered cardiac arrest and
is in critical condition now demar's
uncle is opening up to CNN about his
nephew's status revealing Demar who has
been sedated at the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center since Monday
had to be resuscitated twice they
resuscitate him on the field before they
brought him to hospital and then they
resuscitated them a second time when he
got to the hospital they sedated him
just to give him a better chance for you
know him to just continue to heal better
seems like he's trending upwards in a
positive way Dorian also thanked the
medical staff for saving demar's life
not for them my nephew probably wouldn't
even be here and he says when the whole
thing went down he was in Pittsburgh
watching the game with demar's brother
this heartbreaking seeing him like that
I'm not a crier but like I I never
crashed so hard in my life man just just
to know like like my nephew basically
died on the field and they brought him
back their life both of demar's parents
were at the game when he collapsed and
are by his side as he receives treatment
his parents like they're Fighters I mean
they are like it's one of the best
support systems that anyone can have and
honestly it shows why Demar is so
strong-willed and caring they obviously
are nervous it's it's a little scary for
them
um but they're optimistic because they
know Demar on Tuesday Etc spoke to
Jordan Rooney a spokesperson and friend
of Demars who said the family is
grateful for all the love and support
it's just it's a really tough moment so
to have so many people unite around this
challenging time it makes a difference
it just goes to show like you know we
can't come together even Bengals and
Bills fans can come together and you
know the family is they're honestly just
incredibly thankful they just keep
saying like they're just in disbelief
they're just like wow this is amazing I
can't believe how good these people are
to us Demars family released an official
statement on Tuesday they are deeply
moved by the prayers and kind words and
ask fans to keep Demar in their prayers
I'm just glad he's still alive and able
to fight
um and trying to get better and recovery
and we're just taking it day by day
[Music]
foreign